Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie, Aquaman 2 the Lost Kingdom
Just came out in theaters,
and it's officially the end of the DCEU
So press F to pay respects.
This will be my last post-credits
scene for a DC EU movie.
The next DC movie will be Superman Legacy in 2025
as part of James Gunn's new DCU reboot.
So there's going to be a hot second
when there are no DC movies in 2024.
will break it all down.
The Post-Credits scene in the ending of the movie
either infuriated you
or you're just completely past it
and like you don't care anymore.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There are DC things to look forward to in 2024,
like the Batman Penguin series.
Looks like it's going to be fire that Creature Commandos
series is coming at the end of 2024.
Just no movies from DC in 2024.
They're taking a little break with the movies.
careful for spoilers if you have not seen Aquaman
two yet, but at the end of the movie,
Aquaman and Orm team up to defeat Cordax in Black Manta
to assist affected.
Black Manta was really only the mid bat of the movie,
slowly being consumed by uncontrolled
using the black Trident Cordax
was the ancient king Atlantis brother,
thousands of years old, played by Pilou Asbæk,
Euron Greyjoy from Game of Thrones.
He only appears briefly in his original human form.
In the movie.
way before the fall of Atlantis when it sank beneath
the ocean, when it was still made of seven kingdoms.
Cordax, his brother ruled.
One of the sister nations called Necrus, a.k.a.
the Lost Kingdom, from the comics
which existed in Antarctica.
Negra started to grow more powerful
than Atlantis in the other seven nations
through their use of a special fuel source
called Orichalcum, which is meant to be an analog
for modern day fossil fuels
that polluted the environment significantly.
the Orichalcum was so powerful, so dangerous
that it threatened to mutate the organic life
of the entire world, melt the polar ice caps,
basically change the entire planet in a bad way.
is meant to be a metaphor for the transition
away from fossil fuels and present it
like people wanting to save the environment.
the other nations of Atlantis
barely defeated them and sealed them with blood magic.
Eventually, the polar ice caps in Antarctica
covered the nation of Necrus, Atlantis struck
all record of it in his brother from their records
before Atlantis sank.
So that effectively it became the Lost kingdom.
People just forgot about it. Over the centuries.
until present day when black manta gets the trident
Cordax starts using the magic of it to free himself
through black manta, using blood taken from Aquaman's
royal bloodline, here's the thing, though.
This is where people will be kind of infuriated because
it's kind of a nothing type of ending for the movie.
Especially the main villain caught
eventually is able to free himself.
But they make quick work of him.
He doesn't really have time to accomplish anything
before Aquaman kills him.
Like it's like, Boom, you're out. Then you're dead.
they wind up burying the lost kingdom again
in the polar ice.
He lies to the other kingdoms,
telling them the ORM was killed in the battle
so he doesn't have to go back to prison,
allowing him to go free effectively.
But having him stay off the radar,
basically imply that ORM will come back and help
Aquaman with whoever
would have been the villain of Alchemy in three
had they done a third movie
Aquaman, Mira, his family have a happy ending.
They don't wind up killing his father.
Like all the trailers made you think the baby lives?
Mira, His mother, live and they basically end the movie
pulling in Iron Man one, ending with him
basically copying everything that Iron Man did
at the end of his first movie.
Like it's almost literally a copy paste
of the ending of that movie.
he addresses the world in a news broadcast
where he reveals Atlantis,
his existence to the world,
like when Iron Man revealed his existence to the world.
I am Iron Man and ends by literally
doing the same thing, saying I am Aquaman.
is crazy how similar the ending is.
Like this will either infuriate people
or you just won't care because you're passive.
Like, okay, fine, this is the end of the DCU
while he's giving that speech
though they said at the Post-Credits scene
where he's talking about embracing
both the land in the sea, hand in hand,
enjoying the benefits of both worlds.
As ORM sits down at a dockside restaurant and orders
a burger while dressed in casual human clothes.
Remember, his whole thing in the first movie was that
he wanted to burn, destroy all service dwellers.
So part of the idea is that he's chilled out on that
and he's enjoying
some of the best things about the surface world
during the actual post-credits scene,
which is more of like a mid-credits scene,
you see ORM continuing to enjoy his burger
and catch a cockroach running across his table,
stick it in the burger,
then take a huge bite of the cockroach burger
and they really lay it on.
They like
they added a big crunching sound in post-production.
He smiles, enjoying the cockroach
like it's supposed to be a silly moment that pays off.
Aquaman's speech about ORM turning
good, like he's chilled out
and he's finally enjoying the surface world.
He's now going to try and kill everybody they can see,
But it's also meant to be a silly moment like ha ha.
He doesn't understand that the culture of the surface
world hates the idea of eating that cockroach.
The funny thing about that
is that in some cultures around the world, bugs
like that are viewed as delicacies
and are cooked in really special ways.
So it's not really weird
even though they play the post-credits scene like a ha
ha funny kind of moment and that's it.
There's no second post-credits scene.
Originally there was like a big deleted post-credits
scene that featured a version of Batman.
you probably saw this because Jason Momoa revealed it
months and months ago.
Like, Oops, I was supposed to tell everybody,
We're going to have Batman at the end of our movie.
they filmed two different Batman
post-credits scenes with two different versions
of Batman meant to set up their future crisis
on Infinite Earths ten year movie plan
that the previous regime before James
Gunn had been hired to develop.
this was back when the ending for the Flash
movie was completely different.
Like there was a bunch of Henry Cavill stuff.
They were setting up the next version of the Justice
League, like Justice League
to under this new regime,
not Zack Snyder's version of Justice League.
Do look a completely different version of Justice
League to that involved Michael Keaton's
Batman in Supergirl. Also being on the team.
originally this would have flowed out of the whole idea
that the Flash changed the timeline again
at the end of his movie.
So it wound up being Michael Keaton on the main
Justice League Earth.
So he would have shown up in that Aquaman
two post-credits scene.
But obviously everything changed.
They changed the release order for the movies.
So originally Aquaman two was meant to come out before
the Flash movie and it wouldn't have made any sense.
that's when they filmed the Ben Affleck
Batman Post-Credits scene that Jason Momoa revealed
to the world that was actually meant to be released
before the Flash movie actually came out in theaters.
then as you all saw, James Gunn was hired late
last year after the Black Adam movie came out
like around that same time when Henry Cavill revealed
that he'd come back for a bunch more Superman stuff.
like he literally posted this video on his Instagram
telling everybody
that good things were coming,
like they were going to be making Man of Steel, too.
That a completely different plan
for the future of DC movies in all these Zack Snyder
Snyder verse of Justice League characters
all those movies that they were planning
were meant to be like this new era of the DCEU
building up to a crisis on Infinite Earths movie
that apparently like right when that was happening,
like right as they started doing that stuff,
they hired James Gunn
and he just flat out chose to reboot everything.
Like, okay, we're going to fix the DC Universe
by destroying it first
and just completely starting fresh
That's when Jason Momoa started talking about
this being his last time as the Aquaman character,
but always having a home at DC.
Then Peter Safran, James Gunn's producing partner
who's like the other half of his new Kevin vibe
that he has going on at DC
now, running all the DC movies.
basically said the exact same thing,
reiterating the Jason
Momoa quote unquote would always have a home at DC.
Implying that he would be coming
back is a completely different character.
looking too good. that Lobo cover and I was like, Wow,
look at the guy.
Look at the guy.
I was a big Lobo fan growing up,
so I have every comment.
So that most people, myself included,
just think that that means
that he is coming back as a version of Lobo
because he's been talking about it so much.
On the upcoming two press tour Overall,
I was not a huge fan of Aquaman two.
I feel like it's a pretty weak ending for the DCEU
and a pretty weak post-credits scene to end on to.
Clearly, Warner Brothers was just like,
okay, no more editing this movie.
Like it's fine the way it is, I'll just release it.
There's just move on to the next thing.
Stop worrying about it.
Normally, if the studio kind of given up on the movie
and they knew it was going to be their last
big DCEU movie, you'd think that they would have changed
something to give it a better bookend.
At the end of that Post-Credits scenes.
that'll probably be
my biggest complaint about the movie
is they just kind of let it exist as the way it is now.
Like if they knew it was going to be
the final DCEU movie, they should have had some kind
of moment honoring everything that came before
at the end of the movie, I've already done
a bunch of other videos about how they changed
the Flash movie and like their original plans.
What was going on with Henry Cavill Superman.
There's like a bunch of stuff
that they want of deleting from that movie.
Ra's alchemy in two always sounded like
it was meant to be a relatively standalone movie
with a couple of post-credits scenes
that were connected to this other crisis
on Infinite Earths movie stuff
that they were building up to.
The Flash movie itself
was originally planned to be a much bigger
jumping off point,
setting up crisis on infinite Earths.
James Gunn's new ten year
plan for DC like he announced DC
phase one, essentially like DC
Chapter one, Gods and Monsters.
He didn't announce all the movies that are happening
for the next ten years, just like the first big
phase them the next couple of years,
he already said that that's not meant
to build up to crisis on infinite Earths in the movie.
Like the thing that he's building up
to, like his new version of the Justice
League movies will be completely different,
like a completely different event.
But the pictures that he posted were from Kingdom Come,
so it might be inspired a little bit by Kingdom Come,
at least the next Justice League movie
But it does look like the Batman too, with Robert
Pattinson is going to be fire.
It looks like the Batman
Penguin series is going to be great.
And hopefully the James Gunn era of DC TV
series are also going to be really cool too.
all the ones that will be connected to the DCU.
if you have any questions about what happened
during the Aquaman two movie or the ending
the Post-Credits scene, or just the general future
of DC movies, just write them below in the comments.
I'll probably try to do a full breakdown
of alchemy too, with Easter eggs and references
from the entire movie later this weekend.
There's a bunch of stuff coming out
like we're in the middle of Marvel.
What if Season two episodes
speaking of Snyderverse, Zack Snyder
also released his own Rebel Moon Netflix movie.
I'll try to do a couple videos for that, too.
that's basically him
trying to cook his own version of a Snyderverse
That's more inspired by the Star Wars movies
over at Netflix, like a completely separate vibe.
We will see if he is successful.
Everyone click here for all my marvel
What if episode videos and click here
for that new Henry Cavill Warhammer
trailer for his new TV series
and the new Warhammer movies that he's working on
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!